hi there steve kaufman here haven't done
a video in a while i've had my son and
his family visiting from london
they've gone uh south to portland to
visit some friends so i'm gonna do a
video here i'm gonna talk about habits
and uh in particular
make reference to
flash cards
um
a lot of people use
um
anki
or other sort of spaced repetition
systems
uh for learning languages
i must say i don't really do that i will
occasionally review words before
studying a lesson link or after
but i don't consistently study
with
um
so and and of course a lot of people
swear by that and i guess i swear by not
doing that
uh and i think the important thing is is
the kind of habits that we
can develop
i noticed that my activity with link is
is very much habit-based i'm in the
habit
of downloading downloading some content
from a website i'm in the habit of
processing in that link where i save all
the words that i don't know
to a database and i'm in the habit of
reading so i don't have to think
about what am i going to do today i'll
just do what i'm in the habit of doing
and then i listen and i listen during
the day so it's kind of a had a
a routine a habit
and i think if we get whatever
habit we get into if we are in the habit
of doing our flash guards for 10 or 15
minutes a day
then that's a good thing and that's a
habit
uh
but i'm not persuaded that that
necessarily one habit is better than the
other it depends what we like to do how
we like to spend our time we never
really know and i think this is an
important point we never really know
when we're engaged in a particular
activity
just to what extent it's contributing to
our learning if we are you know i have
read you know russian conjugation tables
or declension tables
and or german or french and i in the end
i can remember it for a short period of
time and then it's gone i'm not
convinced that does much for me but i
think it has some beneficial
influence uh similarly when i'm doing
flash cards i'm never sure how much i'm
really retaining there
um
but what i do know is
that the way i learn for example if i
look at my ukrainian
uh
you know in the last
three months i have created 14 000 links
roughly that means that i have saved 14
000 words
um
so those were words that appeared as
blue on my lesson page and link and then
they were converted to yellow
and
many of those i have seen again and
again in subsequent texts
uh
now i know that the cumulative effect of
that over the three months is very
positive because i can now understand
podcasts
i can read text and i understand a lot
of it
i in a way i understand sometimes
more
than i give myself credit for because
this is another issue habits is one
thing and often we don't give ourselves
credit for what we understand so we kind
of think we don't understand it when in
fact we did understand it so for example
i'll read the text without importing it
into link i'll more or less understand
it then i'll import it into link pick
out the few words that i didn't know
and i discovered that what i has had
assumed to be the meaning in fact was
the meaning
so you know it's a bit of a digression
but sometimes we don't we become again
it's a habit i'm i'm addicted in a sense
to reading these texts in link where i
have my online dictionaries i can
quickly review my yellow words that i
have met before i can look up the new
the blue words so i prefer to read in
that environment but actually i
understand quite well even without that
and this is as a result of
of three months so 14 000 words that i
have looked up in an online dictionary
so now if i were to use anki
you know i was looking up some websites
if you google efficient use of an key or
efficient use of flashcards you'll find
a lot of information people recommending
how you should go how you should go
about using them
they suggest that typically
you can do
10 flash cards a minute
they recommend that you spend 5 or 10
minutes a day on flash cards while i add
let's say that the three months is
roughly 100 days
i add 140 new words a day to my list to
my stack to my deck
so just to review those 140 new words
would take me
what is it
60 what did they say
10 a minute
so 140
is going to be 14 uh minutes 10 per
minute
so quick math here
uh
if i have
140 to do
that's going to take me 14 minutes yeah
what am i saying 14 minutes
so that's just for the words that i
saved today now if i want to review some
words that i had saved previously
uh you know i could very quickly double
or triple that do i really want to spend
an hour a day working through flash
cards i mean i have 14 000 words saved
there
um
i don't think i do
uh
and i find that
by because i'm now interested in the
events in ukraine so much of what i'm of
what i'm reading is about political
events in ukraine so that those words
tend to repeat so i am getting
a sort of spaced repetition system based
on that particular area of interest
when i was reading tolstoy in russian
i would get his vocabulary and the kind
of words that he used so by focusing
your reading on a particular
author or on a particular subject you
will get that concentration
of
key vocabulary and of course the
most frequent words are going to appear
anyway the uh take give come go i you he
therefore are going to show up all the
time so i'm getting enough repetition
but i'm getting it in an environment
that's rich to me that has resonance
that has meaning and i'm seeing the word
you know alive with other words
so i'm happy doing that however that's
my habit it's very easy for me to go and
just do my routine download
link review on my ipad whatever
occasionally go through the uh the words
the you know flash cards
that's my habit but other people have
other habits
so i think the important thing here is
to develop habits that work for you
that you like doing so that almost
without thinking you just go and do
whatever it might be and it might be
reviewing a stack or a deck of
flashcards in anki or it might be
uh
you know
doing a lesson at link or importing
something to study at link i think the
key thing is to have
good habits and you know while i was uh
i actually was looking for my microphone
because i hadn't used it for a while
and so i came across this
and uh
i just mentioned it because i was in st
petersburg
russia uh in
uh 2011
and i was at there on the day of the
city
and i was wandering down
i can't remember which street and
everybody had these things and i asked
this family of russians i said you know
where can i buy one and they said you
know buy one here and they gave me one
and
i just think of it because you know
there's so much
hysteria and hate
now uh
in this whole ukrainian situation and
the russians are being told to hate the
west and hate the ukrainians and you've
got
all kinds of
heated feelings and stuff like that and
somehow you know if if people can just
learn to
uh respect each other
and try to resolve their problems
peacefully
we'd have a lot better world anyway
that's my uh take on habits
uh and language learning bye for now